This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we begin, I wanted to give a shout out to my other podcast mantra.
Some of you may not know that I actually, yeah, I have two podcasts. I have two shows. mantra is basically how I describe it like the spiritual philosophical sister of the psychology of your 20s. Every Monday I talk about a new mantra, something to guide you for the week ahead. Some of the recent ones that I have loved and I think people will resonate with include things like I allow myself to be happy with what I have. I make the best decision with what I know now. I know that love won't pass me and so many more. Honestly, it is such a passion project for me right now.
It allows me to talk about things from a less scientific point of view, but still go really deep. It's also incredibly meditative, and each week I include journal prompts and a weekly challenge and mental exercise to really aid you in a mindset shift. So I would really love if you guys checked it out. If you love the psychology of your 20s, obviously you will love Marjad. Just listen to one episode, try it out. Tell me what you think because I'm also looking for feedback. I'm looking for mantras that you want me to cover. I'm looking for any suggestions for dilemmas or, yeah,
topics that you want me to look at on that podcast. So check it out. Today on the podcast, we are tackling a big question. Why do we grieve past versions of ourselves? Why do we grieve the past in general? Let's be honest. I feel like our 20s are mainly the decade in which we are comparing ourselves to others. Are we doing enough?
Are we as happy as they are? Are we as successful, as beautiful? We can apply that to every facet of our lives. But what if the other person is actually someone that you once were? What if it is yourself, a past version of you? And even further, what if we look back and actually miss this person but don't know how to recover them? In other words, what if our life now isn't as good? What do we do then? It might sound a little bit dramatic, grieving a version of yourself, like they're somehow, you know, dead. Maybe it can feel
a little bit silly. But I think if you really sit with that feeling, if you reflect on who's you were five years ago or even two years ago, you actually might find that quiet ache. A sense of loss, this person isn't coming back. There is nothing you can do to bring them back. Because, you know, that's the weird thing about growing and evolving. It always means shedding something, leaving something behind. And sometimes that shedding, that leaving, it feels like a genuine loss. It feels like a farewell to a very significant chapter and the person you were, the environment you are in, the people you were around, what you spent your days doing, you're saying goodbye to that. We talk a lot about grief in the context of losing a loved one, and rightly so,
but what about grief for our own past identities and our past aspirations, just the past way of being? So my lovely listeners, that is what we are going to explore today. We are going to discuss why we feel this way, what it has to do with identity formation and life transitions. We'll look at why sometimes feeling a sense of loss for past versions of ourselves can mean that we get stuck in the past, even though our current circumstances may be objectively better. And we're also going to talk about that danger, that danger of romanticizing things that have already happened and romanticizing certain memories and certain versions of us that may actually not be as good in reality. I also want to talk about the role of social media, how our narrative self is shaped by how we collect and store memories physically, online, in journals, in photos.
But most importantly, I just want to leave you with some practical advice on how to not fall into the nostalgia trap when it comes to who you were before, how to really validate this form of grief, and really accept. that growing and evolving will involve loss, but that loss is essential to becoming someone better and to improving your life. I fully believe sometimes parts of us have to die in order to make room for other parts of us to grow. And we suffer so much when we think only about what we have lost, not realizing that we would suffer so much more if we had stayed the same. So how do we mourn but also thank those parts of us we kind of needed to kill off in order to bloom into something more beautiful. Well, hopefully you will learn that in this episode. So without further ado, let's get into why we grieve past versions of ourselves. So before we really begin, let's just
start with the basic understanding of what it actually means to feel this kind of grief. What does it look like? What does it feel like when it happens? To really grasp this, we need to understand that what we're experiencing obviously is not exactly the same as grieving that is associated with a real physical death. Think about it. You know, a past version of you hasn't physically died, right? But that particular identity, those specific circumstances, they're just no longer accessible to you in the present. They're gone, but not so much forgotten. They're still present in memory. They're still present in old photos or journals. And that makes the grieving process incredibly complex because it feels like I'm still alive. I could still be that person. But you also know that you can't.
And you know, there's no clear funeral. We don't publicly acknowledge. We don't hold funerals. There's no universally understood ritual to help us process moving from one chapter of our life into another. And so there's no closure, you know, going from being a university student to being a full-time employee, there's a loss there that we don't acknowledge. Going from being someone who was single to being someone in a relationship, even though that's a positive thing, there's still a loss. Moving away from a town that was really important to you or a city or a place, even if it's for somewhere better, there is still a loss. And this brings us to a really crucial concept. It's called disenfranchised grief.
Now, this was a term first introduced by someone called Professor Kenneth Docker. He is basically the world's leading expert on grief and loss. And he essentially understood that there is a kind of grief for things that aren't openly acknowledged or accepted that makes the grief feel less valid. when we mourn things that aren't socially sanctioned or that people don't see as important to mourn, sometimes we have this dual feeling of loss and sadness and then also kind of shame and silliness. Like, oh my gosh, this is so dramatic. That was so long ago. No one actually died.
I should just move on. We also tend to lack external validation for how we're feeling. when we do open up about it, people can be quite dismissive. Like, what do you mean you're grieving a past version of you? There's real things to be grieving. And so that makes you feel even more isolated, confused, like something's wrong with you, like you've got a really serious problem that you don't want to talk about, but you also feel very strongly about.
Something that is misunderstood about grieving past versions of ourselves is that we don't necessarily want to go back to the, that time. Instead, what's really happening is this internal emotional process that mirrors a passing. It mirrors this closing of a door of what you could have been, of different life paths you could have taken, of certain emotions and feelings and experiences that were really valuable at that time that you realize you can't relive. So ultimately, what we're mourning is a discrepancy between who we were then and who we are now and how we see those two different versions of us as being different. What did they have that we don't have, that we therefore miss?
And then the second punch that comes to us is acknowledging like, oh my God, I could never get that back. Does that mean that I'll never be happy in the future? Obviously, there's a huge emotion that comes into this and it's nostalgia. Nostalgia with a melancholic tinge. You look at old photos, you listen to music from five years ago. Yes, it's a warm, nice, fuzzy feeling, but then comes the sadness, then comes the yearning. And that yearning, that longing is incredibly painful because an element of longing and yearning is powerlessness, is not being able to do anything about it. I think that nostalgia is such a complicated emotion. I honestly would go on the record as saying it is the most complex emotion that we experience as humans because it is equally powerful
And then the second punch that comes to us is acknowledging like, oh my god, I could never get that back. Does that mean that I'll never be happy in the future? Obviously, there's a huge emotion that comes into this and it's nostalgia. Nostalgia with a melancholic tinge. You look at old photos, you listen to music from five years ago. Yes, it's a warm, nice, fuzzy feeling, but then comes the sadness, then comes the yearning. And that yearning, that longing is incredibly painful because an element of longing and yearning is powerlessness, is not being able to do anything about it. I think that nostalgia is such a complicated emotion. I honestly would go on the record as saying it is the most complex emotion that we experience as humans because it is equally powerful
and beautiful as it is despairing and uncomfortable. Like what other emotion is like that other than maybe like love and heartbreak? Nostalgia does have a role to play, right? It's an incredibly mentally protective thing to have access to moments in the past that made us feel happy and to have that kind of pool of joy and goodness to draw from in hard times. But when we let nostalgia have too much of a say, it can actually create kind of a P-to-Pan syndrome where we fight against growing up, we push back against growth and evolution because we feel so terrified of having to say goodbye. we feel so terrified of the idea of things being over. A 2020 study actually found that nostalgia in that way can make us feel lonelier and more disconnected
because it gives this sense of being pulled between two different worlds, who we were in the past, this version of us we want to cling to, and the possibility and the potential of someone in the future that we might equally enjoy being but who hasn't been discovered yet. but I do also think that nostalgia, if we really think about it, is just proof that you are living a life that you are proud of. You would not yearn for those memories you would not yearn and long for those past versions of you if you didn't feel, you know, proud of them. If you didn't like who you were then, if you hadn't done things that really made you happy and excited you. I think living with constant chronic nostalgia often means appreciating what it represents, that you have lived a happy life and that there are things you loved about the past,
but you cannot let it convince you that just because there is good in the past, there cannot be anything better in the future. When that occurs, that is when our grief for the past dictates our actions in the present in a really detrimental way, often by forcing us, to keep making the same choices and staying the same. So this grief brings about nostalgia. It also brings about confusion and mental disorientation. You might find yourself thinking, who was I then?
Who am I now? How do I explain these different versions of myself to people? You feel very disconnected from old experiences. You realize that you've grown, but you also fundamentally understand that some people only know you as the version of you then. And so that can bring up the big R. The big R. Regret. regret over how you behaved in the past. Regret that that version of you lives on. Regret that you didn't act differently. You know, how often have you wondered, how would my life have turned out if I just made a small different choice?
If I just knew what I knew now, if I just appreciated that time or that. opportunity more. Maybe what we're experiencing when we grieve or we miss versions of ourselves is the ability we had then to make different choices which we can't make now. But what you've got to realize is that you made the best decision with what you knew then. It's something that we actually talked about on a recent episode of Mantra the other day. How could you have known? You're judging your past self based on information you have now that you didn't have access. to. So it's an unfair judgment. It's in a symmetry that is entirely unfair for former versions of you. They can't beat that evidence. Like, you know what I mean? Like you're judging them based on what
you know now, thinking that they must have known it, they're not realizing how naive you probably were. But also, how do you know that the choice your mourning wouldn't have led to a worse outcome that you have been saved from. There's this really beautiful quote that actually I wanted to pull out of that episode of mantra I was talking about that I really, really love from Maya Angelou, where she says, do the best you can until you know better, then when you know better, do better. And I think that's a really beautiful way of making peace with the fact that they did make mistakes, but you still love them anyway. This past version of you didn't have all the information, but you have grace towards them. And you know that it's all a stepping stone
into being a better version of you in the future. Keep your eyes pointed on the future. I think our investment, our fascination, our obsession with the past also occurs because of something that I've mentioned before, the Polyana effect. So this refers to our cognitive tendency to essentially remember positive experiences more than negative ones. And so when we look back at who you were before, who you were in high school, who you were in college, who you were with that person, often it is so much easier to recall and see the good experiences and the fun times and the things that we liked rather than what we disliked or struggled with at the time. I need to talk about this experience I had recently. So recently I was on tour around Australia for my book, Person in Progress, and part of that tour brought me back to, Canberra is like the capital city of Australia if you don't know that and it's where I went to
university. It's where I started this podcast actually. And I, in the lead up to going back, I was so nostalgic. And I was really quite sad that I was never going to be 18 again. I was never going to be 21 again in this little university town with all those people having like the time of my life. I had so much freedom. I had so much fun and I was really getting in my head about it. And I went back and when I was back there, I actually went back to my old college dorm and I snuck into the building, which I don't think I was allowed to do. My intentions were pure and I knocked on the door to my old college room and this like, wonderful girl answered and I was like, this is so strange, but I used to live here. You can tell me to go away, but I carved my name into the back of the back of the door, the closet door,
and I just want to see it. I just want to see if it's still there. And, you know, she let me in and she was so nice. Like, she was so lovely. And I opened the door. And there it was. And I expected to just be like so overwhelmed with grief and sadness at the passing of time. And I actually just felt so unbelievably happy and grateful that I wasn't still there, that I wasn't still in that timeline. I was like instantly reminded in that moment of all the things that I had hated about that time in my life. Obviously, it was fun, but I forgot about how broke I was. I forgot about how unsure I was. I forgot about how little I slept, how much I was drinking, how terrible I felt all the time. I forgot about how lonely I was at times, how much phomo I had. I forgot about the terrible
meals that I would eat. I forgot about how cold it was. Our autobiographical memory is not a perfect video recording. It's actually reconstructive. So every time we recall a memory, we're not pulling it from a file. We're actually rebuilding it. And that process can be influenced by our current mood, by our beliefs, even by external cues. So that means that every time you pull out a memory, it becomes easier for you to erase the bad parts from your retelling of it to yourself. It becomes very easy to romanticize a period because the specifics have faded and our current feelings will often color our perception of the past. So if you're not doing well right now, if you're sad, if you're lonely, if you're really, if you're really, if you're
really just struggling in your life. You go when you pull out a memory from the past, your brain, given its current state, is going to make that memory look beautiful and wonderful, and it's going to convince you that that was the best time of your life when actually, when you were in it, it probably wasn't. Essentially what that means is that you're not just grieving a past self, you're grieving the narrative and the story you are telling yourself about the past. And that can be really dangerous when you are, like I said, going through a tough time. It can really manifest in a difficulty accepting your current self, struggling to fully integrate the new you with the old you. And I think it really keeps you from living in the present.
Okay, we're going to take a short break. But when we return, I want to talk about why this is so much more common in our 20s and also how to deal with it, how to manage, how to stop romanticizing the past, how to live in the now. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the
problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, health, your person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that
trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcast.
Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big time, to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever
you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, learn the hard way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. Grieving previous versions of ourselves is a process that is necessary.
It's normal. It's also incredibly sped up and intensified during the decade that we're in. There are so many profound shifts and life-changing moments that happen when we're in our 20s and even our early 30s. It's such a period of big change and changes that happen one after another that it means that our identity feels particularly unstable where we are up right now. So there are more revisions and versions of ourselves to grieve than I think in any other time of our life. This is particularly because of physical environmental transitions that we're going through and how many chapters close and then open quite quickly in succession. I'm going to give you some examples of why this happens a lot in our 20s.
firstly, you will see a lot of people leaving formal education and starting careers. So you lose the student identity, the structure, the clear academic goals, the specific peer group, the sense of being on a path and you're really thrust into an adult world of work where the rules are different. You turn from being a student to a professional. It feels like there are certain things you can't do anymore, certain environments you can't access. You can't go and study in the library with your mates. Like, it's all different to you. And so it's trying to reconcile who you were before, who you are now, and say goodbye to them.
We also find that in our 20s, obviously, a lot of us move away from home. So this involves the loss of family proximity, childhood routines, a sense of belonging, and also a specific place or community that wants to find you. As you're building a new home and you routine and you sense of belonging, it's beautiful, it's magnificent. There's so much growth there. There's also an appreciation of like, okay, I'm never going to be five again. I'm never going to be 12. It's never going to be a beautiful summer day when I'm 15 and I have no responsibilities.
There's also changes in relationships. So typical experience in your 20s, hopefully you guys know this, is drifting away from old friends who no longer share your path. You're also navigating new romantic partners, starting significant. relationships, ending significant relationships, we know that relationships and connection form a great part of our identity. So if you've always had a best friend and now you no longer do, it feels like a part of you is missing. If you enter a new relationship, if you leave a relationship, it's actually quite a stressful thing to integrate that new label, single, partner, girlfriend,
boyfriend, boyfriend into who you are. All of this comes down to identity shifts. I also think we need to talk about significant personal growth and trauma that happens during this defining period. This could include overcoming major life challenges, experiencing profound shifts in who you are. For example, if you are someone who has recovered from a severe mental illness, a severe eating disorder, and you're no longer feeling like you're defined by that illness, you've shed that identity. that's going to feel incredibly liberating. You're going to feel very proud of yourself. It also carries the weight of acknowledging what you've lost in the process.
Perhaps a familiar, albeit unhealthy coping mechanism, perhaps a distorted sense of control, but also time. You've lost time. And part of that grief is really realizing, you know, you're only going to be 17 once. You're only going to be 20, 21, whatever age it is. and you can feel like because of what you were going through that that period was wasted.
I know it probably doesn't help coming from me, someone who doesn't know your story, doesn't know who you are. It wasn't wasted. You were working towards, you were battling against something very, very difficult. That is not a waste, ever. And you've got to realize you're judging your previous self based on who you are now. and the person who you are now only came into existence because of the sacrifices and the difficulties experienced by your previous self who had to work through that you have so much to be thankful for
for them and how strong they were how much they put into this journey how much they put into this growth and it kind of feels weird that you're like killing them off but they had to die right they had to go for you to be where you are now whenever i feel sad about missing who I was before, I always think about these plants that my grandma has. So in her backyard, she has these plants. I think they're called hydrangees. Hydranges, I think that's it. And whenever I'm at her house, she always has me cut the old flowers off these plants.
Like, she has me, like, basically, like, butcher them and cut all these limbs off. And one time I asked her, I was like, why do you need me to do this? Like, aren't you destroying the plant? And she said, you know, it's because those parts need to be removed for new flowers to come in. If we didn't do that, the plant would die under the weight of basically these old dead parts of itself. And I feel like that is such a beautiful metaphor for my own personal development. It's why I feel more at peace now with aging, with closing chapters, with moving on with my life from old relationships, places, things, old versions of me. I don't want to die being who I was at 23 for the next 60 years.
比如，她让我，基本上，把它们砍掉，剪掉所有这些枝丫。有一次我问她，我说，你为什么需要我这么做？我说，你难道不是在毁掉这株植物吗？她说，你知道的，这是因为必须移除这些部分，才能长出新的花朵。如果我们不这样做，植物基本上会在自身这些老去的枯枝烂叶的重量下死去。我觉得这对于我个人的成长来说，是一个非常美妙的隐喻。这就是为什么我现在对变老、对结束篇章、对生活中的旧关系、旧地方、旧事物以及旧自我的释怀感到更加平静。我不想在接下来的60年里，带着23岁时的那个自己死去。
I don't want to constantly try to relive stages of my life that are no longer representative of who I am. I think that that loss and that pain shows that you are on the right path. Perhaps the final reason that I can really think of that this scares us a lot is that the past versions of us feel very, comfortable. There's something that is known and there is a lot in the future that is unknown. There's a lot of mystery there. And so perhaps what is really intertwined in with this is a fear of the unknown, a fear of our future self. If the self is constantly changing, how stable is our identity really? Who are we? Who are we really actually at our core? What parts of us stay the same? How do I know that I'm even the same person?
我不想不断地试图重温那些不再代表我是谁的人生阶段。我认为那种失落感和痛苦表明你正走在正确的道路上。也许我能想到的让我们对此感到恐惧的另一个真正原因，是过去的我们感觉非常舒适。有些事情是已知的，而未来有很多是未知的。那里有很多神秘感。所以，也许这里面真正交织在一起的是对未知的恐惧，对未来自己的恐惧。如果自我一直在改变，我们的身份到底有多稳定？我们是谁？我们内心深处到底是谁？我们的哪些部分保持不变？我怎么知道我还是同一个人？
So it's not just grief. It's very existential questions. It's questions of the self. It means that you're probably a very deep thinker if you are sitting there and trying to figure out who you were then, who you are now. What does that mean for me? Who am I going to be in the future? It's a bit of a mind puzzle, actually. But, you know, if this grief goes unacknowledged or unaddressed, it can.
所以这不仅仅是悲伤。这是非常存在主义的问题。这是关于自我的问题。如果你坐在那里，试图弄清楚你曾经是谁，你现在是谁，这意味着你可能是一个非常有深度的人。这对我意味着什么？我将来会成为谁？这其实是一个心理谜题。但是，你知道，如果这种悲伤得不到承认或处理，它可能会。
have less than desirable outcomes. It can contribute to prolonged sadness, even depression, especially if the feeling of loss is so intense that you isolate yourself or if it triggers an identity crisis, you can have difficulty forming new connections because you're constantly trying to revert to past relational patterns or struggling to adapt to new social environments. And I think critically, idealizing the past can lead to chronic dissatisfaction with the present.
产生不太理想的结果。它会导致长期的悲伤，甚至抑郁，特别是如果这种失落感如此强烈以至于你将自己孤立，或者如果它引发了身份危机，你可能会发现在建立新联系时遇到困难，因为你总是试图回到过去的关系模式中，或者难以适应新的社交环境。我认为至关重要的是，将过去理想化会导致对现状的长期不满。
because you're constantly comparing your life to a romanticized version of what once was. One factor that is undeniably complicated this process for you and I in the modern age is social media, is just actually most digital technology. Think about it. Every single version of who you are now is probably immortalized online. Old Facebook posts, blurry Instagram photos, Snapchat photos from literally, decades ago sometimes. They serve as digital for prints, constant reminders of who we once were. And this digital archive can make it incredibly difficult to let go because it creates a perpetual
因为你总是将你的生活与曾经被浪漫化的版本进行比较。在现代社会中，毫无疑问让你的我经历这个过程变得复杂的因素之一就是社交媒体，实际上也就是大多数数字技术。想想看。你现在每一个版本的自己可能都在网上永垂不朽。旧的Facebook帖子，模糊的Instagram照片，甚至几十年前的Snapchat照片。它们充当了数字足迹，不断提醒我们曾经是谁。这个数字档案让人极难释怀，因为它创造了一个持久的
comparison point. It's like having an old photo album that updates itself daily, showing you who you once were, even when you're trying to move forward. It's like when you go through a breakup up and people say to delete all the photos of you with your ex because otherwise you'll look back at the photo of you on a nice holiday or having a great time and think that it was all beautiful. That's pretty difficult when it's you and you're trying to break up with an old version of yourself. The highlight real effect as well on social media definitely amplifies this. Listen, all the stuff that you probably posted online was probably the best photos that you had. probably the photos where you looked the hottest, probably the times when you felt the happiest,
对比点。这就像拥有一个每天都会更新的相册，向你展示你曾经的样子，即使你正试图向前迈进。这就像你经历分手时，人们会叫你删掉所有你和前任的照片，因为否则你会回头看你在一个美好的假期或玩得很开心的照片，然后认为这一切都是美好的。当你试图和一个旧版本的自己分手时，这相当困难。社交媒体上的高光时刻效应也绝对放大了这一点。听着，你可能发布到网上的所有东西大概都是你拥有的最好的照片。大概是你看起来最辣的照片，大概是你感觉最快乐的时候，
that's why they made it online. And yet, right now, you're comparing a very messy, unfiltered version of your life with a version of you that was curated by past you. It's so funny when we compare to people online. Everyone always says, you know, social media isn't real. You've got to remember that for you as well. I often think about this when I look at photos of myself when I was, smaller, like physically smaller when I weighed less. And I'm like, God, she was so fit. Like, she was so fit and healthy and like, I don't look like that anymore now. And then recently I found an old phone and I was going through it and I was like, oh, look, I remember posting that photo and I went back and I found the photo. And then I found like the 20 other versions of that
这就是为什么它们能发布到网上。然而，现在，你却把一个非常杂乱、未经滤镜的生活版本，与一个由过去的你精心策划的自己进行比较。当我们与网上的人进行比较时，这太搞笑了。每个人总是说，你知道的，社交媒体不是真的。你也必须记住这一点。当我看到自己过去更小的时候的照片时，我经常会想到这一点，比如身体上更瘦的时候，当我体重更轻的时候。然后我想，天哪，她身材真好。就像，她身材和健康都那么好，而且我现在的身材已经不那样了。然后最近我找到了一部旧手机，我翻看它，然后我想，哦，看，我记得发布过那张照片，然后我回去找到了那张照片。然后我找到了大概另外20个版本的
photo when I was like, wait a second. Like, I angles everything, poses are everything. I. I I know that now. How come I'm not applying that to past me who knew the same thing? Let's also touch briefly on attachment theory. Now, obviously, we often discuss this in the context of relationship with others, but here's the nuance. We form attachments not just to people, but to aspects of ourselves and our roles and our identities, even our routines.
照片，当时我想，等一下。角度就是一切，姿势就是一切。我。我 我现在知道了。为什么我没有把它应用到过去的那个也知道这一点的自己身上呢？让我们也简要谈谈依恋理论。现在，很明显，我们经常在与他人关系的背景下讨论这个问题，但这里的细微之处在于。我们建立依恋的不仅是人，还有我们自己的一部分、我们的角色和身份，甚至是我们的日常生活。
So losing these internal attachments can also evoke a similar form of of grief to losing a person. The reason that you were so attached to a previous identity that you had is probably because you really liked that person and you felt safe and comfortable as that person. And so having to kind of rip two people apart, rip old you and knew you apart is going to feel like disentangling a whole lot of complex loyalties and attachments and insecurities and securities between who you were then and who you were now. So how do we navigate closing an old
因此，失去这些内在的依恋也会唤起一种类似于失去一个人的悲伤。你之所以对以前的身份如此依恋，可能是因为你真的很喜欢那个人，并且作为那个人你感到了安全和舒适。因此，不得不把两个人撕裂开来，把旧的你和新的你撕裂开来，会感觉像是理清了你当时和现在的自己之间一大堆复杂的忠诚、依恋、不安和安全感。那么我们该如何应对一段旧感情的结束呢？
chapter? How do we grieve without getting stuck in the past? I think, firstly, it's so important to acknowledge this grief. And I was going to say validate it, but I know that some people hate that word. But you know what? Acknowledge and validate the grief. This is the absolute first step. these feelings are not silly or irrational. If you feel a pang of sadness or longing for a past version of yourself, acknowledge it. Say to yourself, this is a real feeling. I'm obviously very sad. I'm obviously feeling things that are complex.
篇章？我们如何在不陷入过去的情况下悲伤？我认为，首先，承认这种悲伤非常重要。我本来想说验证它，但我知道有些人讨厌这个词。但你知道吗？承认并验证这种悲伤。这是绝对的第一步。这些感觉并不愚蠢或不理智。如果你对过去的自己感到一丝悲伤或渴望，承认它。对自己说，这是一种真实的感觉。我显然很难过。我显然在经历复杂的情绪。
And I can just sit with that for a little while. I don't have to put it in a box. I don't have to resolve that feeling right away. What if you actually just let yourself for three minutes, three minutes right now, just feel really sad about who you were then. I find that when I'm really stuck, I do really need to just put what's in my brain into something physical. For me, that's journaling. And I know it's such a cliche thing, but a problem on a page is a problem halved. One of the journal prompts that I find incredibly powerful is to write about what
我可以和这种情绪相处一会儿。我不必把它装进盒子里。我不必马上解决这种感觉。如果你真的让自己花三分钟，现在就花三分钟，去为那个时候的你感到真正的难过，会怎么样呢？我发现当我真的陷入困境时，我确实需要把大脑里的东西变成实体。对S我来说，那是写日记。我知道这听起来是个老生常谈的事情，但把问题写在纸上就等于解决了一半。我发现非常有力的一则日记提示是，写下我
I loved about them, what I missed about them, and whether I feel like it's because I'm missing something now. Am I just reflecting on that time from a place of happiness? Or is there genuinely something that I want to change in my life that this nostalgia is trying to remind me of? Remember, this is a form of disenfranchised grief. So if other people don't understand it, If other people make you feel weird about it, if other people say, I know, I've never experienced that, it doesn't really matter. It's an emotion that exists within you means it's valid enough. Think also part of this is practicing self-compassion. Think about how you treat a friend who was going through a really tough transition.
爱他们什么，我怀念他们什么，以及我是不是觉得那是因为我现在缺少了什么。我只是在一个快乐的地方反思那个时刻吗？还是说我生命中确实有什么东西想要改变，而这种怀旧试图提醒我这一点？记住，这是一种剥夺了权利的悲伤。所以，如果其他人不理解它，如果其他人让你对此感到奇怪，如果其他人说，我知道，我从未经历过，那其实并没有关系。这是一种存在于你之内的情绪，这意味着它足够有效。我想这其中的一部分也是练习自我同情。想想你是如何对待一个正在经历艰难过渡期的朋友的。
Think about what you would say to a sibling or someone you really loved who came to you and said, I just can't let go of who I was before. what advice would you have for them? What do you need to hear? The thing I always remind myself of that makes me feel better is that if I didn't grow, I wouldn't get to experience the world. If the alternative that I would want is to go back to the past and relive certain points of my life, I would be avoiding so much beauty in the future.
想想你会对一个兄弟姐妹或你真正爱的人说些什么，如果他们来找你并说，我就是放不下以前的我。你会给他们什么建议？你需要听到什么？我总是提醒自己的一件事让我感觉更好，那就是如果我没有成长，我就无法体验世界。如果我想要的替代方案是回到过去并重温我人生的某些特定点，我将错过未来中如此多的美好。
Growing older, experiencing new things, that is the human experience. That is what I am here for. for. I'm here to observe. I'm here to feel. I am here to learn. And part of that is learning who I'm going to be at 32. Who am I going to be at 45? Who am I going to be as a mother? Who am I going to be as a grandmother? Who am I going to be as a wife as an artist as someone older and wiser? That is part of the human experience. It's a gift. It's a blessing to be able to get there. Instead of viewing your past self as well as something that is completely abandoned or forgotten, you also have to remember that this is a foundational layer upon which your current self is being built. The old you is still
变老，体验新事物，这就是人类的体验。这就是我来这里的目的。我来这里是为了观察。我来这里是为了感受。我来这里是为了学习。其中的一部分就是了解32岁的我会是什么样。45岁的我会是什么样？作为一个母亲，我会是什么样？作为一个祖母，我会是什么样？作为一个妻子，作为一个艺术家，作为一个年长而睿智的人，我会是什么样？那是人类体验的一部分。这是一份礼物。能够走到那一步是一种福气。不要把过去的自己视为一个完全被抛弃或被遗忘的东西，你还得记住，这是你当前的自我得以建立的基础层。旧的你仍然是
part of your story. You've just expanded on it. You've just refined them. Think of it like a really beautiful building that has undergone renovations and additions over time. The beautiful original structure is still there. It's contributing to its current form. and character, you're just adding to it. Yes, I know we've been using the word death a lot. Maybe the better word is evolution. What kind of small behaviors can you still recognize that you do today and what kind of things did you learn in the past that are still with you today
你故事的一部分。你只是在此基础上进行了拓展。你只是对他们进行了提炼。把它想象成一座非常美丽的建筑，随着时间的推移，它经过了翻新和扩建。美丽的原有结构仍然在那里。它正在为其当前的形式和特点做出贡献，你只是在它上面添砖加瓦。是的，我知道我们一直在频繁使用“死亡”这个词。也许更好的词是“演变”。你今天仍然能认出自己有哪些微小的行为是你一直在做的，你在过去学到了哪些东西，至今仍然伴随着你，
that shows that your past self is still very much alive and well. They're just not center stage. I think this really allows us to see identity development not as a threat to your stability, but as a very exciting opportunity for continuous learning, for mastery, for becoming. If you were who you were at 24 for the rest of your life, that would make you a finished product. That would make you very still, very stagnant, very bored. That's not a way you want to live.
这表明你过去的自己依然充满活力。他们只是不在舞台中央。我认为这确实让我们看到身份的发展不是对你稳定性的威胁，而是一个非常令人兴奋的机会，可以进行持续的学习、精进和自我实现。如果你在余生中一直保持24岁时的状态，那会让你变成一个成品。那会让你非常静止、非常停滞、非常无聊。那不是你想过的生活。
The pain of growing is actually quite a beautiful thing. And whilst it's okay to acknowledge the past, try to gently redirect your energy to who you are now. Ask yourself and sink deep into your current passions and goals. Something that I really, really think is important for everyone to have is a project of some kind. Often when we are experiencing intense emotions about the past, very existential emotions about identity, we really need something that's going to get us out of our mind and into our bodies or into a very active mental state, into a flow state. This like really saved me last year when I was going through a very difficult time,
成长的痛苦其实是一件非常美妙的事情。虽然承认过去是可以的，但试着温和地将你的能量重新引导到现在的你身上。问问自己，并深深沉浸在你当前的热情和目标中。我真的、真的认为对每个人都很重要的是拥有某种项目。通常当我们对过去体验到强烈的情感、对身份有非常存在主义的情感时，我们确实需要一些能够让我们摆脱大脑、进入身体，或者进入非常积极的心态、进入心流状态的东西。这在去年我经历非常困难的时期时真的拯救了我，
having very existential thoughts. I just realized that I spent a lot of my day. I gave myself a lot of time to think. And at that point, like, I didn't need to do any more thinking. There was nothing that thinking about my thoughts was going to get me. Like, I had done enough. What I really needed to do was start acting on something else. acting on a different impulse, a different interest, a different point of fascination.
当时我有很多存在主义的想法。我只是意识到我花了很多时间在思考上。我给了自己很多时间去思考。在那个时候，我觉得，我不需要再思考了。思考我的想法并不能带来任何结果。就像，我已经做得够多了。我真正需要做的是开始对其他事情采取行动。对另一种冲动、另一种兴趣、另一个着迷点采取行动。
So I got a project and that's how like my running journey really began. Now I'm running like four or five times a week and I love it and I never thought I was going to be a runner. But I realized that I needed something else to think about in that time instead of giving my brain the opportunity to just ruminate. Part of me thinks that the reason I was so hung up on past versions of myself and thinking about, the passing of time and change and all that was because I was just bored. Like I genuinely think I was just bored and my brain was like, all right, let's pull something out of the cabinet that will take you a lot of time to think about and come to an answer on because there is no answer, right?
所以我接手了一个项目，这就是我的跑步之旅真正开始的方式。现在我一周跑步四五次，我喜欢它，我从未想过自己会成为一个跑步者。但我意识到我需要在那个时间里想点别的，而不是给大脑胡思乱想的机会。我一部分的心思觉得，我之所以对过去的自己那么执着，一直在想时间的流逝、变化之类的事情，是因为我真的太无聊了。我由衷地觉得我当时只是无聊，我的大脑就像是在说，好吧，让我们从柜子里拿出一件需要你花很多时间去思考并得出答案的事情，因为根本没有答案，对吧？
Let's choose this. And what I really needed to do was like say to my mind, okay, but how about we do this instead? And what this was was something real and tangible and in my environment. like I needed to do something with my hands and with my body. So get a project, get a self-improvement project, get a travel goal, get a fine, like have a finance goal, a savings goal, go back to uni, like have something that you need to work on that you can care about and think about specifically something that is future orientated that can get you out of ruminating on the past into projecting good things, good energy, all your resources, your time into the future. This also might sound a little bit woo-woo for some of you, but consider doing some sort of symbolic ritual of letting go, or for celebrating evolution. Whilst they're not formal grief rituals, you can create your own personal ways to acknowledge the transition and to say, yes, I'm going to grieve here, I'm going to formally close a chapter and kind of make peace with it. You know, this could be like writing a letter to your past self, thanking them for the lessons
让我们选择这个。我真正需要做的是对我的大脑说，好吧，但是我们换做这个怎么样？而这个“这个”是一些真实的、有形的、存在于我环境中的东西。就像我需要用我的双手和身体去做点什么。所以去接一个项目，找一个自我提升的项目，找一个旅行目标，找一个财务目标，储蓄目标，回到大学深造，总之要有一些你需要努力去关心的、思考的事情，特别是面向未来的事情，能够让你从对过去的胡思乱想中解脱出来，把美好的事情、美好的能量、你所有的资源和时间投入到未来中去。对于你们中的一些人来说，这听起来可能有点玄乎，但考虑做某种象征性的放手仪式，或者庆祝演变。虽然它们不是正式的悲伤仪式，但你可以创造自己个人化的方式来承认这种过渡，并说，是的，我要在这里悲伤，我要正式结束一个篇章，并与之达成某种平和。你知道，这可以像是给过去的自己写一封信，感谢他们教会你的
learnt, saying goodbye to what no longer serves you, or conversely creating something like a future self-vision board. You could also, I don't know, this sounds really strange, but find memorabilia and photos from a past version of you, past version of you who was in a relationship or who was a certain person at a certain time and put them in a box, send them out to see. bury them somewhere. Do something like that that symbolically kind of cuts a tie, mainly with parts of yourself that might not be helpful to bring into the future, but also parts of yourself that you're finding you are too actively grieving to move on and you need to just be like,
课程，向不再为你服务的事物告别，或者相反，创建一个类似于未来自我愿景板的东西。你还可以，我不知道，这听起来很奇怪，但找到你过去版本的纪念品和照片，那个处于恋爱关系中或在特定时间是特定某个人的过去的你，把它们放在一个盒子里，把它们送到海里。把它们埋在某个地方。做一些这样能象征性地切断联系的事情，主要是与那些可能不利于带入未来的自己的一部分告别，但也是与那些你发现自己过于积极地悲伤而无法释怀的自己告别，你需要表现得像，
okay, cool, we aren't going back there. There's nothing that we can do to go back there. So let's formally say goodbye. I think there's also a celebration in that. Buy some champagne. get some cupcakes. Really, this is for the moments when you are super stuck. Say goodbye. Have a funeral for the past version of you and then celebrate what you are now. Celebrate this new chapter of life. You know, I read this quote that says every day you wake up is another little life. Is another birth. And I just think that's so beautiful. I'm like, yeah, each day is its own little life. It's its own little lifespan. And that really helped me in, you know, feeling better about being in the present rather than feeling torn to the past, stuck in the past, and constantly ruminating over the future, constantly thinking about it.
好吧，酷，我们不会回到那里去了。我们无能为力回到过去。所以让我们正式说再见。我认为其中也有庆祝的成分。买点香槟。买点纸杯蛋糕。真的，这是为你陷入绝境时的时刻准备的。说再见。为过去的自己举办一场葬礼，然后庆祝你现在的样子。庆祝生活的新篇章。你知道，我读过这样一句话，说你醒来的每一天都是另一个小生命。是另一次新生。我只是觉得这太美妙了。我想，是的，每一天都是它自己的小生命。它有它自己的小寿命。这真的帮助我更好地接受活在当下，而不是感到被过去撕裂、困在过去，并且不断地对未来胡思乱想，总是想着它。
Okay, we are going to take one more short break, but when we return, we have our listener questions for the day. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator. available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out
好的，我们要再进行一次短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我们将解答今天的听众提问。所以请留在我们身边。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了坚韧意志、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊恐的许多问题
about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man.
都是压力造成的。经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》，即T-W-O-Percent。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女朋友》中……天哪，这是同一个人。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼，绝不。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得黛安·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一切的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·hill，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我愿意在某天谈论可卡因，但只是为了让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Kornayne, Ryan, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学艺》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安、科尔内恩、瑞安，有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
我们不知道什么时候做得够多了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
那是两个不同信任级别。我希望你真正成为一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难学艺》中，进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《艰难学艺》并立即收听。
Okay, we have some amazing listener questions for this episode. When I went to Instagram and said, what do you guys want to know? What dilemmas are you facing in terms of grieving past versions of you? A lot of you were like, I really need to hear this. I really need to hear this episode. And here are my, here are my thoughts.
好的，我们在这一集中有一些非常精彩的听众提问。当我登录Instagram并说，你们想知道什么？在悼念过去的自己方面，你们面临着什么困惑？你们中的很多人都说，我真的需要听这个。我真的需要听这一集。这里是我的，这里是我的想法。
So thank you for sharing. Let's start with this first question. How do I actually know when it's time to leave a past version of me and step into a new one? What are the psychological signs? Oh, I loved this question. I was like, I could make a list that goes on for days. But I'm going to just leave you with three things that I think are really telling. Firstly, you feel an inner sense of restlessness.
所以谢谢你们的分享。让我们从第一个问题开始。我怎么才能真正知道什么时候该离开过去的自己，迈向一个新的自己？有哪些心理迹象？哦，我很喜欢这个问题。我想，我可以列出一个长达数天的清单。但我只想给你们留下三点我认为非常能说明问题的。首先，你有一种内在的焦虑感。
You feel like your life currently makes you feel very highly strong, makes you feel quite anxious, makes you feel like your mind is racing, uncomfortable. You feel this sense of like, I want to be doing things. I want things to change. I want things to move. You don't know what it is yet, but you know something needs to change. so you're really craving different things. I think also you might find yourself thinking there has to be more. There has to be more to life.
你觉得你目前的生活让你感到精神高度紧张，让你感到相当焦虑，让你觉得大脑在飞速运转，很不舒服。你有一种这样的感觉，我想做事。我想改变。我想让事情动起来。你还不知道那是什么，但你知道有些事情需要改变。所以你真的渴望不同的事情。我想你可能还会发现自己在想，一定还有更多的东西。生活一定不仅于此。
What if I meant for something else? What if this isn't who I want to be for the next 10 years? Could I imagine myself here for the next 5, 10 years? And the answer keeps coming back as no. So there's this low hum of discontent, this low hum of restlessness. Secondly, the old version of you feels kind of like
如果我是为别的什么而生的呢？如果这不是我想在接下来的10年里成为的人呢？我能想象自己在这里待上5年、10年吗？而答案一直都是“不”。所以有一种对现状的低沉不满，一种低沉的焦虑感。其次，旧版本的你感觉有点像
self-abandonment. You notice that you're constantly saying yes to things you don't actually want to do. You're constantly finding yourself bored in situations that previously made yourself made you very happy. You can't talk to the people you were friends with during that time.
自我抛弃。你注意到你一直在对自己其实不想做的事情说“好”。你发现自己在那些以前让你非常快乐的情境中不断感到无聊。你无法与那些时期交的朋友说话。
You feel like you're hiding parts of yourself. It just feels like a betrayal. It feels like these people aren't really matching up. And finally, I think that you can tell it's time to close an old chapter if it feels like it's taking more of you to keep the door open than it would to shut. So what I mean by that is that it's taking more effort for you to keep returning to this old life, returning to this past version of you, than it would to accept the future. I remember when I first moved to Sydney from Canberra, I would go back to Canberra all the time to see my friends, all the time to just be in my old neighborhood. And I was like, wait, it's taking me
你觉得自己把一部分自我隐藏起来了。这简直就像一种背叛。感觉这些人真的不太搭调。最后，我认为如果你觉得维持这扇门开着比关上它需要付出更多的努力，你就能看出是时候关闭一个旧篇章了。我的意思是，维持这种旧生活、回到过去的自己，比接受未来需要你付出更多的努力。我记得我刚从堪培拉搬到悉尼时，我总是回堪培拉看望我的朋友，总是回去待在我旧日的街区。然后我想，等等，这花了我
so much effort to try and maintain this former life. Maybe this is a sign that, like, I need to move on. Like, I'm not meant to be here anymore. That's a really important sign, I think. The second question is around forgiveness. How can I actually forgive my past self the mistakes that I made when I didn't know any better? I grieve the fact that she could have made better choices. Oh gosh, don't we all? There is something that every single one of us regrets doing or not doing. I promise you that.
太多的力气去试图维持这种以前的生活。也许这是一个信号，就像，我需要前进了。就像，我不属于这里了。我认为这是一个非常重要的信号。第二个问题是关于原谅的。我如何才能真正原谅过去的自己，原谅我在年少无知时犯下的错误？我为她本可以做出更好的选择而感到遗憾。哦天哪，谁不是呢？我们每个人都有过后悔做过或没做过的事。我向你保证。
Hold it in your mind right now. There's something you regret. There's something that you cringe at. So I want you to know it's a universal experience, first of all. People are just better at hiding it. People also aren't going to come out and say and talk about their regrets. It's this weird thing that we don't do. I think the fact that you can acknowledge that you made a mistake or that you didn't make a good choice is all the evidence that you need that you have grown.
现在把它记在心里。有些事你很后悔。有些事让你感到尴尬。所以首先，我想让你知道这是一种普遍现象。人们只是更擅长隐藏它。人们也不会主动说出来并谈论他们的遗憾。这是我们不做的一件奇怪的事情。我认为你能承认自己犯了错误或没有做出好的选择，就是你已经成长的所有证据。
The version of you back then who made that mistake, who did the wrong thing, would not be a able to acknowledge that she did the wrong thing and she wouldn't be able to handle, you know, the humility that that would take. So you've obviously taken a lot of responsibility. I also want to remind you, you had no idea back then of how everything would have turned out. You really didn't know. You made a mistake because that's the only way to grow. Literally the only way to learn is to do the wrong thing or to have someone else teach you who was done the wrong thing. So you really need to have some grace, have some kindness towards your past self. I also want you to stop and focus on your life right now and think about four things
当年犯那个错误、做错事的那个版本的你，是无法承认自己做错了事，也无法承受这需要付出的谦逊的。所以你显然承担了很大的责任。我也想提醒你，那时候你根本不知道一切会如何发展。你真的不知道。你犯了错误，因为那是成长的唯一途径。学东西的唯一途径就是做错事，或者让一个做错过事的人来教你。所以你真的需要对过去的自己多一些优雅，多一些善良。我也希望你停下来，专注于你目前的生活，想想有哪四件事
that you are incredibly grateful for that have happened in the past six months. Four things that probably wouldn't have happened if you weren't on this timeline and if you weren't on this path. think about it you have a lot to thank this person for this past version of you for for making a mistake because even if you didn't like what she did even if you are frustrated by her stupidity or her naivety or whatever it is it still meant that you you came across and you ended up experiencing these beautiful things so you do have a little bit to be thankful for let's talk about this third question now. I have a dilemma. How do I live with my family who still see me as a past version of myself? That's tricky. I feel like everyone expects continuity from us. It's like that
是你非常感激在过去六个月里发生的。四件如果没有经历这条时间线和这条道路就不会发生的事情。想想看，你有很多理由感谢这个人，感谢过去的那个自己犯了错误，因为即使你不喜欢她所做的事，即使你对她的愚蠢或天真感到沮丧，无论那是什么，它仍然意味着你遇到了并最终体验到了这些美好的事物，所以你确实有那么一点值得感激的事情。现在我们来谈谈第三个问题。我有一个困扰。我该如何与仍然把我看作过去自己的家人一起生活？这很棘手。我觉得每个人都对我们抱有持续性的一致期望。这就像那种
experience where like your grandma keeps buying you the same presence based on something that she found out that you liked like back when you were three. Like I had this period in my life where everyone would buy me rabbit stuff and I was like I don't even like rabbits anymore. Like because I had a rabbit when I was like seven and until I was like 16 every single Christmas I would get like rabbit slippers rabbit you know um post-it notes like rabbit clothing and it was very sweet but it's kind of similar to that but on a more intense level you kind of want to hold people and scream at them and be like I'm not that person like can't you see I've changed like know me for me now um tricky thing is you just have to let them be wrong about you you just have to let them be mistaken
经历，比如你的奶奶一直根据她发现你小时候喜欢的东西给你买同样的礼物。比如我人生中有过这样一段时期，每个人都会给我买兔子相关的东西，而我想说的是，我甚至已经不喜欢兔子了。因为我大约七岁时养过一只兔子，直到我十六岁左右，每个圣诞节我都会收到像兔子拖鞋、兔子便签纸、兔子服装之类的东西，这非常可爱，但它有点类似于那种情况，只是在更密集的层面上，你有点想抱住这些人然后对他们尖叫，我是说我不是那个人，难道你看不出我变了吗，现在请为真正的我了解我。棘手的事情是，你只能让他们对你有错误的看法，你只能让他们误解你。
the more authentic you are actually the less you try and convince them, the more I think it comes across to them, the more it signals to them that you are different because you're living it and you're showing them it and you are vibrant in who you are now and your identity that you feel comfortable in. So spend less time trying to convince them because I feel like sometimes then we feel like we have to convince ourselves
你越真实，实际上你越少试图说服他们，我认为这越能传达给他们，越能向他们表明你是不同的，因为你在践行它，你在向他们展示它，你在你现在感到舒适的身份中充满活力。所以少花点时间试图说服他们，因为我觉得有时候那样会让我们觉得我们必须说服自己，
and more time just living in the president, and living organically and authentically as the version of you that you really want to be. Our final question for the day, I gave up recently on a career that I thought would make me happy because I was going broke. But I still wish almost every day that I had done it. What is your advice? My advice to you is that it is not too late. It is never too late.
而要把更多的时间花在活在当下上，作为你真正想要成为的那个版本的自己，有机地、真实地生活。我们今天的最后一个问题，我最近放弃了一个我以为会让我快乐的职业，因为我破产了。但我几乎每天都希望自己当时坚持下来了。你有什么建议？我对你的建议是，现在还不晚。永远都不晚。
You have all the time in the world to go back and try again. Maybe the time just wasn't right. Do you know how many actors, authors, musicians, sports stars, small business owners, anybody you can think of, have stories about them quitting? Almost every single one of them. Or have stories about setbacks? Every single one of them does. Maybe this is just part of the story. This is part of your origin story.
你有大把的时间可以回去再试一次。也许当时的时机不对。你知道有多少演员、作家、音乐家、体育明星、小企业主，你能想到的任何人，都有关于他们放弃的故事吗？几乎每一个人都有。或者有关于挫折的故事？每一个人都有。也许这只是故事的一部分。这是你起源故事的一部分。
The beginning of a really amazing, cool chapter that you were about to write. of getting back on the horse. Also, there is this huge tension between passion and practicality, right? And I talk about this in my book, actually, this idea that people often think that if you've given up on your dreams, you are somehow like undisciplined or you don't actually want it. And what we have to realize is that practically money is important. You need money to live.
开启一个你即将书写的非常惊艳、酷炫的篇章。重新振作起来。另外，在激情和实用性之间存在着巨大的张力，对吧？实际上我在我的书中也谈到了这一点，人们常常认为，如果你放弃了你的梦想，你就在某种程度上没有纪律，或者你其实并不想要它。而我们必须意识到的是，实际上金钱是很重要的。你需要钱来生活。
You need certain things to be well and to survive and to survive, and to thrive as a human being. Because you put your dream on pause for money, that doesn't mean that you are any less entitled to that dream. It doesn't mean that you deserve it any less. You just do what you needed to do. So my advice is to find small ways to keep practicing the dream career or the dream thing that you want to do on a smaller scale
你需要某些东西来保持健康、生存下去，作为一个真正的人类繁荣发展。因为你为了金钱把梦想暂停了，这并不意味着你对那个梦想的权利有丝毫减少。这并不意味着你对它的应得减少了。你只是做了你需要做的事。所以我的建议是找到一些小方法，在较小的规模上继续实践你梦想的职业或你想做的事情，
and just to keep out of it and know that you have heaps of time. Okay, as we wrap up today, episode, I want to leave you with this final thing. The grief you might feel for your past self isn't a sign that something is wrong with you or that you are stuck. And it is certainly not a sign that all the good in your life has already happened and is in the past. It's actually a very profound indicator that you are growing. I fully believe discomfort is the first sign of evolution. You are adapting. You are learning. You are becoming this new person. and that you're going to be so proud of.
并坚持下去，要知道你有充足的时间。好的，当我们今天结束这一集时，我想给你们留下最后一段话。你可能为过去的自己感到的悲伤并不是你出了问题或你被困住了的标志。它当然也不是你生活中的所有美好都已经发生并成为过去的标志。这其实是一个非常深刻的指标，表明你正在成长。我坚信不适是进化的第一征兆。你在适应。你在学习。你正在成为这个崭新的人，
Embrace this process. Embrace the pain. Embrace how messy it is. And remember that every version of you that fades does make space for a stronger, wiser, more real version of you. That's really what you're creating. You're creating space for them, even if they're not quite there yet. Thank you again for listening to this episode. If you've made it this far, I want you to leave an emoji in the comments that best represents
一个你会为此感到无比自豪的人。拥抱这个过程。拥抱痛苦。拥抱它的凌乱。请记住，每一个逐渐淡去的旧版本的你，都在为更坚强、更睿智、更真实的那个你腾出空间。这才是你真正正在创造的东西。你是在为他们腾出空间，即使他们现在还没完全到来。再次感谢你收听这一集。如果你听到了这里，我希望你在评论区留下一个最能代表
evolution and growth for you. Make sure that you are following along wherever you are listening and send this episode to a friend, a colleague, a family member, anybody who you think would really, really resonate with it. Make sure that you are following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast so you can contribute to our listener questions plus so much more. And make sure you listen to Mantra. I'll leave a link in the description below.
你经历的进化和成长的表情符号。确保你在你收听的任何地方关注我们，并将这一集分享给朋友、同事、家人，以及任何你认为会对此产生强烈共鸣的人。确保在Instagram上关注我@That Psychology Podcast，这样你就可以参与我们的听众提问以及更多内容。别忘了收听《Mantra》。我会在下方的简介中留下链接。
But until next time, stay safe. be kind, be gentle to your past, present, and future self. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
但直到下一次，保重。善待自己，对过去、现在和未来的自己保持温柔。我们很快就会再次交谈。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧意志、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《2%》。在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方，搜索T-W-O-Percent。在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一切的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more. important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《吃一堑长一智》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法坦诚交流的真诚对话，而你是在和一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就非得这么做。请在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并吸取教训。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。